il me parle pas des emplois fictifs du
rassemblement national voyage où nous a
soutenu par l'opa de vos emplois fictifs
que vous sortez vos affaires
l'algérie soit ne se défasse tout en moi
que ça soit arrivé là vive l'algérie
vive l'algérie vive l'algérie merci à
jean beitia d'être avec nous qui a été
habillée par guillaume genton celle-ci
lui dire tu vois combien vous avez pris
pour mettre ça mais bon merci pour le
spectacle geste commercial merci à vous
deux on peut plus un peu plus ses hauts
faits s'il vous plaît on a merci à m
batik avocat spécialisé en droit pénal
d'être avec merci mais non merci d'être
là et merci à bernard montiel merci mont
bernard d'être là on a vu les images
est-ce que vous avez été vous les
chroniqueurs choqué par les propos de
bernard hier paye tout parce que nous
c'est vrai que dans cette émission on
dit tout ce qu'il y en a qui rit ça a
dérangé ou pas du tout le genre noir
non mais moi pas du tout en fait je suis
plutôt partisan de dire un peu tout ce
qu'on pense
mais en plus je comprends parfaitement
bernard moi la première fois que je
venais de chimie dans l'émission j'avais
dit que j'étais par exemple contre le
voile chez les mineurs ça s'est
transformé camp avec des menaces de mort
par téléphone
on va te crever ta famille on va
t'égorger moi je suis vraiment partisan
pour qu'on puisse dire tout ce qu'on a
envie de dire malheureusement d'un côté
comme de l'autre que ce soit dans les
extrêmes à gauche ou à droite
aujourd'hui quoi qu'on dise ici des gens
sont pas d'accord avec vous ils veulent
vous en mettre plein la gueule alors
bernard
merci d'être là montbernard t'es
vraiment un amour et tu sais qu'on
t'aime je te sens extrêmement fatigué en
tout cas oui oui c'était fatigant et
cette journée va rue on va revenir sur
ta sur ta journée sur ce que tu as vécu
vous a été choqué guillaume genton bah
oui je suis choqué que aidé cette
polémique là je vois pas en quoi dire
vive l'algérie ça veut dire que qu'on
n'aime pas la france on peut dire vive
l'algerie et aimer la france
je pense que le problème ça vient du
vous algérie si berne à la veille la
suède ou l'espagne s'est avéré payant
mais voilà le montre cette affaire aussi
parce que j'ai vu les messages qui a
reçu bernard hill énormément de comptes
anonymes et ça pose une vraie question
sur le débat de l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux après avoir été de
laisser des gens prendre des comptes
anonymes et menacer les gens
gratuitement comme ça je trouve ça
scandaleux
alors on va bernard va nous raconter
dans un instant à ce qu'il a vécu
isabelle à moi je reconnais que hier
quand il est vide la phrase vive
l'algerie moi ça m'a surpris ce jeudi
mais c'est le bécasseau c'est pas le
débat
j'ai juste dit ça c'est parce que j'ai
évidemment que la phrase m'a pas choqué
évidemment que la suite m'a complètement
traumatisé on en a parlé
jésus trouvé que la phrase n'était pas
utile mais juste comme ça quoi je dis
c'est le débat c'est benzema s'est
gardée il était au coeur du débat il
était au coeur du débat parce que il
avait choisi ses mots et effectivement
les réseaux sociaux se sont enflammés
mais moi j'ai un crimine pas les réseaux
sociaux c'est la société qui aujourd'hui
volcanique et effectivement quand vous
dirai ça grave c'est bernard c'est
vraiment pour moi sur ce et c'est un
coin samassa ma déprime et bien c'est
vrai il a dit vive l'algerie et alors tu
combien de fois tu dis vive la tunisie
fois que j'ai dit ok mais comme a dit
julio me l'aurait dit vive la suède ça
c'est ça vous prouve le malaise qui est
actuellement extrêmement graves à des
millions de personnes d'origine suédoise
non mais attendez mais moi j'ai pris la
même chose que vous juste pour avoir dit
vive la france
donc je vais ouvrir là mais moi je vais
chez moi ma famille menacée de mort je
suis menacé de mort j'ai porté quatre
plaintes au commissariat pour menaces de
mort et pas sur les reins pas seulement
sur la somme et dans des messages
personnels on va te crever on va crever
tes enfants ou ses concerts où tu
habites et ses fonctions en ayant moi
j'ai j'ai été obligé de prendre un garde
du corps dont il se trouve que le garde
du corps et est un bénévole mais ils
m'accompagnent partout mais je suis
effectivement menacée avec vous une des
bénévoles le vrai ouais ouais c'est la
double peine passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pas très bien mais est-ce que
ce que je veux dire c'est que quand on
quand on quand on a des convictions et
qu'on les esprits sur les réseaux
sociaux que ce soit les veaux ou les
miennes ou n'importe lesquels bien sûr
que vous avez toute une partie des
comptes de réseaux sociaux qui vous
attaquent et et qui veut menace et qui
vous pourrissent votre t elle ça fait
partie de la règle du jeu moi j'ai
intégré ça les a dérangés quand il a dit
vive l'algérie mais attendait alors sur
le fond moi je condamne fermement toute
forme de violence est ce qui vous est
arrivé je le condamne
exactement comme je pense que vous
condamnez ce qui m'arrive voilà ce que
je pense que en démocratie le désaccord
ne doit pas être un crime donc chacun
doit pouvoir dire ce qu'il veut pouvoir
exprimer ses convictions sans être
pourri sans être condamné et sans être
menacé donc ce qui vous arrive et ce qui
m'arrive et condamnent de toute façon
parce que encore une fois en démocratie
le désaccord n'est pas un crime d'accord
bon donc moi sur le sur la forme je
condamne fermement toute forme de
menaces ou de violences
à partir du moment où on extrait un avis
maintenant sur le fond je pense que vaut
ce que vous avez dit sur le forain et
encore une fois sans partage et les
menaces dont vous avez fait l'objet
c'est un cri du coeur parce qu'en
réalité vous êtes un peu comme beaucoup
de français aujourd'hui un nouveau
porteur de valises ce qu'on appelait les
vols les porteurs de valises ya 70 ans
ce sont ces français qui se mobilisaient
pour aider à la décolonisation de
l'algérie est aujourd'hui nous avons
effectivement toute une frange notamment
des élites dirigeantes mais aussi de
français qui interviennent sur les
plateaux télé qui sont des nouveaux
porteurs de valises c'est à dire qu'ils
aident effectivement toute une partie de
la population maghrébine à coloniser la
france
alors bernard je dois revenir
montbernard hier te dis vive l'algérie
oui on l'émission franchement voilà
états unis bien mais s'il vous plaît et
tu as eu un différend le mans domaine ah
oui dès monaco variable qu'est ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui
mais toute la journée ça a été un
déferlement incroyable
je tiens d'abord à remercier il ya eu
des milliers franchement des milliers d
habitants de ma vie de gens qui me
disaient
et d'abord kim affirmé leur soutien et
qui m'aimait des coeurs c'est très
bouleversée aujourd'hui très ça soit tu
te sens vraiment très ému bernard oui
c'est très bouleversant mais il ya eu
des messages extrêmement violent
extrêmement violent pourquoi quand vous
va d'abord on veut me décapité comme
l'autre professeur qui regarde j'espère
tu finiras décapité comme certains
parents français et là moi aussi je
dirais villes d'algérie sais pas quoi
c'est profondément choquant alors je
veux dire ouais je suis à la fois blessé
et déçu que l'on en soit encore là notre
époque si vous voulez cesser de vivre
ensemble gens ciblés qu'on essaie de
vivre ensemble bon ils veulent diviser
les partis de jean bessis avait dit
viser mieux sur aviez hier c'était
c'était de ça moi monsieur ravier hier
je lui ai rien dit de spécial je lui ai
dit j'ai été choqué quand il parlait de
monsieur benzema mois benzema je suis
ravi qu'il revient dans l'équipe de
france mais lui nous sort attend dé nous
sort et c'est l'algérie le match et
encore mais arrêter quoi moi j'ai eu
envie de dire vive l'algérie parce que
j'aime l'algérie et les algériens comme
je dit vive la france
je suis français en plus je me suis
ravie elle pensait que j'étais algériens
alors envoyé camarades sont pas très
brillant alors je suis pas là attendez
je suis pas là je suis pas le porte
parole de ravier ce soir c'est je suis
pas là pour le défendre
je dis simplement que quand on a des
opinions qui sont les vôtres qui sont
affirmés il faut souffrir
effectivement ce genre de choses sur les
réseaux moi personnellement ça fait des
années que je suis menacé jeux réseaux
et des préalpes sinon merci pas ça c'est
que je reçois des messages pire que
celui pire que celui de tyler va pleurer
sur miam mais c'est pas ça le faux lac
métier vous arrivez de sa mère vous
aussi moi je suis un homme de 19 ans
maintenant et si je prône gimone mais
c'est quoi un veillant s'excuse moins
tolérants bernard excuse moi à partir du
moment où tu expriment une opinion
politique ce que tu as fait
effectivement il faut accepter les
tiberi elle gérait bien sûr il faut
accepter pourquoi il faut attendait dans
le débat qui avait hier par rapport à
benzema etc tu été confronté un
politique un politologue avis nous y ait
moins de temps à oublier c'est un
politique
donc toi tu étais là pour le contredire
donc tu as un message qui contredit le
sien et donc par définition que
politique
donc si tu s'il est effectivement tué
quelqu'un de fragile qui n'acceptent pas
ce genre de choses et pas des saints
faut rester dans ton cas
il faut pas venir s'exprimer
politiquement jessica montell qu'on a
invité soit juste un mot ces crimes moi
ça fait quatre ans que je subis ça je
n'ai jamais eu le droit à une émission
je n'ai jamais eu droit à ce salaire
dérisoire des messages comme on vient de
le faire ce soir
rien à voir toi tu ailleurs tu as droit
au retour ça bien qui je pense moi je
pense pas mal surtout la personne je
pense à tous les gens qui me tous les
jours sans insulter sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ressort zerbaz de mort mais
vous aussi pourquoi pas bon non mais bon
face au vaudois rendent assez de morts
que je vous ai mis dans le groupe pour
aller au but hâtif
il ya des gens qui méritent la vingt dix
ans ne cherchez pas les citer mais pas
des autres
si on pouvait mettre m même être bâti qu
on ne peut pas dire des choses fausses
comme celle que vous êtes en train de
proférer monsieur messier lorsque l'on
fait de la politique lorsque l'on
intervient sur les réseaux sociaux il
n'ya rien accepter savait parler de la
violence
ça n'est pas grave c'est pénalement
répréhensible c'est une infraction je
sais et les infractions sont pénalement
répréhensible et je sais que vous le
savez oui je sais que vous le savez
puisque vous êtes vous même renvoyé
devant le tribunal correctionnel le 27
septembre pour avoir justement eu un
usage disons pas le vin très tendancieux
au mois de septembre mais c'est pas de
la violence là c'est autre chose serait
épargné monsieur pour avoir justement
udc le 20 juin
envoyez vos fiches c'est le 20 juin ou
alors cette part était alors vous
préférez vous gâte à la sortie puisque
ça a été renvoyé au mois de septembre
puisque le préfet a un devoir de réserve
du cannet sortira je vous expliquerai
votre dossier à la sortie ou la dionée
si tu remercies c'est important parce
que vous avez eu un tweet qui est une
infraction pénale et voyant pas les
passes avant le procès ce genre de
tweets voulez vous ils ont lieu tous les
jours procès d'un film monsieur sont
effectivement un usage vous dit
votre vie en société c'est important
parce que c'est l'argent mais si on
n'est pas le procès dure nous tiens les
menaces zero
les menaces de mort qu'a subis monsieur
montiel c'est une infraction
c'est une infraction pénale c'est une
affaire qui est pénalement répréhensible
ce n'est pas grave c'est extrêmement
grave alors parce que effectivement ce
genre de menaces si on les prend à la
légère et si on les balaie d'un revers
de main et bien à ces menaces est
passible des mêmes menaces m vous
accepteriez de venir me défendre allez
voilà merci bernard montiel jusqu'à
plaimont berne à eux qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ça a été hier soir date et délivre
la fin démarrer dès la fin c'était alors
collabos avec ta gueule d'arabe
tu es la honte de la france fait j'ai eu
droit
j'étais très surpris j'avoue parce que
d'avoir juste dis vive l'algérie et je
leur dis vive l'algérie je suis très
choqué qu'on ait pu réagir que de cette
façon mais extrêmement violemment alors
sur le coup je me suis dit et puis là
jusqu'à ce tweet là où on me mets ont la
rage et capite enfin ils sont malades
quoi les gens mais mais là encore je
veux pas ramener à ma petite personne
bon moi j'ai l'habitude ça fait 30 ans
que tu as peur aujourd'hui
non non non sincèrement non tu as porté
plainte
oui tu as porté par tout régenter plane
oui j'ai appelé le ministère de
l'intérieur
le groupe phare us qui va s'en occuper
on va rire parce qu'on va trouver
effectivement qui s'est déjà il ya des
pistes il ya une puce à l'oreille facile
même à trouver ce qui est curieux parce
que ces gens là qui insultent
gratuitement sous couvert d'anonymat
il faut qu'ils sachent quand même que
l'impunité c'est fini là bas c'est pas
des insultes et des menaces de mort oui
le sentiment d'impunité pour les auteurs
c'est fini maintenant on retrouve les
gens très facilement et je crois quand
même déjà retrouver cette personne
d'après le petit coup de fil que du tout
à l'heure alors évidemment je porte
plainte
évidemment je vais pas laisser passer ça
c'est inadmissible je ne fais pas que
pour ma petite personne je le redis
c'est tous les jours qu'il ya des gens
qui se font insulter menacer de mort
c'est intolérable alors ça suffit a lens
on enlève l'anonymat sur ces réseaux
sociaux de merde parce que les réseaux
sociaux c'est à la fois formidable à la
faute et un art que j'étais dessus
oui mais voilà donc à ce moment là mais
non non non
me retire berna maintenant on a est ce
que aujourd'hui tu vas faire très
attention à ce que tu dis est ce que ça
va est-ce que ça va deux traumatisés
c'est pas si aujourd'hui ça m'a
traumatisée cette violence et cette ce
déferlement mais je vous assure c'est
incroyable je ne sais pas trop dire tout
ce que j'ai eu comme gros mots adéquats
et tout ce qu'on m'a souhaité quoi alors
quoi dégager la télé lente de la france
tu soutiens l'arabe benzema des trucs
mais c'est extrêmement choquant enfin je
veux dire moi qui suis ouvert à tous le
monde moi je prends ici la tolérance la
bienveillance on s'est plutôt que je
suis aimable et bienveillant général
j'ai été profondément choqué que je suis
avec ceux qui pensent comme toi
pardon uniquement et ceux qui pensent
comme vous nous annoncez vous voyez
maintenant du mouvement
mais en fait j'ai j'ai appelé des
copains policier aujourd'hui suite à ça
un peu pour savoir quoi faire dans ces
moments là parce que je ne savais pas du
tout que je connais c'est pas encore le
principe de pharos mais le premier truc
qui m'ont dit ils m'ont dit tu sais
vraiment tu en perds tes propos
aujourd'hui à la télé parce qu'il me dit
aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui pour
très peu passent à l'acte mais d'une
manière surdimensionnée et ils m'ont dit
oui ils m'ont repris l'exemple de la
première fois ils m'ont vu dans
l'émission il me dit pour ça fait très
attention parce que tana aujourd'hui qui
dérape
mais pour rien du tout donc aujourd'hui
effectivement on est dans l'obligation
maintenant bas de se taire de ne plus
pouvoir dire ce qu'on pense parce
qu'elle a certains qui sont prêts à
passer à l'acte de manière ultra
violente et sachez quand même que je
trouve que ça c'est à dire oui
absolument
romao madame il fallait prendre ces
menaces au sérieux oui puisque moi
d'ailleurs quand j'ai appelé moi j'ai
fini bon voyez j'ai reçu ça c'est quand
même très violent que vous en pensez
alors eux ils entraient dans le prix 20
e ils ont là un an bernard peut pas
accepter ça mais je n'accepte pas je
vous le transmets mes yeux il était
c'était très très sérieux pour eux mais
c'est très sérieux quand on dit on va te
décapité comme le professeur
c'est une insulte d'abord à cet homme
mort à sa femme nommée sinon de la gtc
c'est violent c'est choquant c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui
j'étais bizarre quand elle écoute et je
ne suis pas fragile genre ne rêvez pas
je ne suis pas fragile
j'espère pour vous merci j'enquête ça
parce que c'est tellement violent mais
je le redis encore aujourd'hui moi je
soutiens benzema je suis content qu'il
intègre l'équipe de france je soutiens
l'algérie est un pays merveilleux parce
que je soutiens la tunisie mais vous
voulez mars
jeudi mais vous pouvez vive la france
mais vous avez raison vous pouvez vous
pouvez admettre que d'autres pensent
différemment que vous annoncer que moi
sur les réseaux sociaux les rangs je
suis très rap de service je suis traité
de [ __ ]
je suis traité de [ __ ] de maison et si
on fait jamais des missions spéciales et
on a pensé ce que je veux moi je lutte
contre toutes les violences et les
autres toutes les malades de mesures
salutaires soit plus de mal choqué par
vos propos car oui mais qu'est ce que
vous reprochez à mettre quelques comment
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
quelqu'un qui gentiment sur un plateau
d'une vive l'algérie mais oui comment on
pourrait fait d'accord avec moi si les
moines en mettant des rives l'espace
accessoires et contre la carrière mais
la question
on a le droit de pas être d'accord avec
quelqu'un qui est d'accord avec moi mais
parce que là d'accord une ride
aujourd'hui la situation entre la france
et l'algérie est extrêmement tendue à
geri müller s'est pas vive l'algérie
entend cieux avec l'algérie donc il faut
pas considérer que l'algérie c'est un
pays comme un autre s'est prêté m et
bâti qu'est-ce que vous avez été vous
est ce que vous êtes choqués par les
propos de jean messia qui est qui et qui
dit que quand on voit la vive l'algerie
c'est ça ça choque évidemment c'est
choquant ça contrevient une liberté
fondamentale puisque ce sont quand même
des libertés que vous prenez au
quotidien la liberté d'expression et
cette liberté d'expression j'ai vraiment
prochaine là bas dit elle ne saurait
être elle a le droit de le dire dans le
peuple a dit ça mais il a le droit
d'être contesté cette liberté
d'expression elle ne peut pas être à
géométrie variable
et puis à l'heure du polyamour on peut
aimer l'algérie on peut aimer la fumée a
fermé la suède on peut aimer l'espagne
l'un n'est pas en contradiction claude
je veux dire il faut pas être binaire
c'est pas on aime la france et on n'aime
rien tant aimé plusieurs mêlées meziane
qu'on dirait qu'il ya un contexte
complexe enfin le jeu fini par alléger
le contexte vous le voyez à travers
votre prise non pas
n'est pas du tout les milieux français
même chose que m je voudrais donner à
part la bernard le pour le couple le mot
de la fin
montbernard toi aujourd'hui tu es dans
quel état tu es ce que tu vas vivre
pareil ce que tu vas être pareil dans
l'émission est ce que tu vas changer est
ce que ça va te faire réfléchir
est ce que c'est le voilà c'est celle de
l'événement le plus traumatisant de ta
carrière
ah oui franchement oui break puis 36 ans
que je fais de la télévision je suis
choqué par cette violence mais je suis
choqué aussi par l'état la société
accepte ça on en arrive là à s'engueuler
parce que j'ai dis vive la vie c'est ça
ou c'est un cauchemar
c'est ce que je disais tu te rends
compte un peu et c'est sérieux malaise
qui division alors cette division s'est
récemment dit j'ai un très petit coin
c'est insupportable cette division il
faut pas se diviser
on est tous dans la merde on est tous
dans la même galère il faut s'aimer
il faut être ensemble il faut être
bienveillant c'est terrible de des trucs
pareils effacés les gens réalisent pas
bernatchez chocolat mais il ya eu des
mots gentils aussi juste pour un petit
mot gentil pour bernard ya des articles
qui sont sortis sur toi aussi où
visiblement les gens disent twitter
jubilé parce que tu a défendu benzema
l'algérie et que tu as eu le soutien des
internautes
donc les gens t'aiment aussi à des
articles concernés c'est ce qu'il a dit
au début mais c'est pour le rassurer
pour les rassurer
c'est une première pour la pour 30 m et
si tu veux venir dormir à la maison
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]